hey what's going on is Bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday December 19th 2016 what's
going on how are ya
oh Jesus Christ my [ __ ] computer
every five seconds do you want to
download this do you want to do this now
do you want to do it in an hour should I
remind you later on tonight lady Jesus
Christ he's [ __ ] goddamn I don't know
man I'm under this [ __ ] at all just the
level with which that sits [ __ ] I
guess because of Technology I am able to
do this you know if it was back in the
day I would not be able to do this what
is this you ask
maybe he didn't ask maybe I'm doing that
thing where I'm putting words in your
mouth but if you did ask you know but
doing a podcast you know I guess there's
always a price to pay and I think that I
think that that's one to grow on
maybe that's the lesson I swear to god I
want to start a [ __ ] church I got to
do it you guys been watching that uh
that woman from King of Queens
she played uh the beautiful wife you
know so the guy who drives the truck did
you know Debs well how they've always
done sitcoms the honeymooners hey I
[ __ ] Drive a bus and you know I'm the
wisecrack can be pretty wife well these
days Alice Paul right the babymaker
right let's know what they did something
like that little [ __ ] ice box in the
corner you know and then you get into
the 60s right 60s was like the blue ball
era of of sitcoms you don't I mean you
had I Dream of Jeannie the [ __ ] guy
would teach us wouldn't bang her I've
talked about this [ __ ] before I remember
watching it as a kid it's like why don't
you like rubbing up against her or
something you know I don't even know
what sex was you know why cuz it was no
internet now if there was internet back
when I was watching that show and I was
like seven or eight you
I would have been like what is he well I
hate your [ __ ] for first Johnny style
over the [ __ ] genie lamp you know I
would know all this extra [ __ ] that's
what the [ __ ] is wrong with kids
nowadays it's like they just say take it
Alamelu I'm going on an old man ran they
get on these [ __ ] computers right the
parents are like me they don't know how
to work them they're not even interested
in them you know we're in the [ __ ]
corner making homemade apple cider
getting ready for the holidays you know
wearing a Christmas sweater that we
think actually looks good we're not
wearing it ironically well I got my
Christmas sweater job my [ __ ] mother
sewed this together for me when I was in
high school still fits
you know sweaters always still fits
because they stretch they like the sweat
pants for your torso you know it takes a
while like if you have a homemade
sweater you know one of those lobster
fisherman ones that your mom would make
you know and she just give it to you in
the bag that she bought the yarn and you
know then one day you'll look at it and
some [ __ ] moth started eating at it
and you just like is it the 1800s really
a [ __ ] caterpillar learnt got its
[ __ ] pilot's license and now is eating
my sweater this is like so [ __ ] 1826
how is this happening right now for the
love of God mom can you go to the rayon
store you know can you make me a [ __ ]
polyester knit a sweater how about why
don't you do that why can't you do that
I mean Jesus Christ these [ __ ]
children that's the problem with all the
mothers nowadays you know what I mean
they do them in the [ __ ] yard they
just won't let go of it I'm just [ __ ]
with you what kind of woman knows how to
knit anymore you know trying to find a
woman that knows how to knit is like
trying to find a guy that no still knows
out of hunt you know I mean and that
even goes for the [ __ ] rednecks
you're not doing it the way you [ __ ]
you're you're you're way less [ __ ] I
don't know what four-wheeler [ __ ]
ancestors hunted
let's talk myself into a corner those
like that I don't want to do the hacky
you know saying your grandfather will
first had sex with the [ __ ] relative
you know I don't want to say that I
didn't want to go down that road I don't
even know if that's true but how the
[ __ ] did that start you know what I mean
one [ __ ] guy bangs his sister and
then all of a sudden everybody out there
that has a four wheeler is doing it you
know what I mean thinking that's just
dig like they don't have facebook you
don't have to be lonely I like how
they've gotten more aggressive on that
farmers only when they've really just
started [ __ ] on [ __ ] city folk
you know any city folk just don't get it
and they still make themselves look
stupid city folk just don't get it they
could go with global warming they could
go with overpopulation they could go
with quality of air quality of life
space there's so many different
directions that hey you want to come
back to my place and you go there it's
like some [ __ ] City apartment you
know what I mean with like the kitchen
is in the bedroom you know in the bed
folds down from the wall and you can
[ __ ] attack them that way you know I
mean some intruder trying to come
through their window may say to folks
just don't get it then they go to their
spray right [ __ ] got your own parking
space you're not driving around the
block like [ __ ] nine hours trying to
find alternative side of the street
[ __ ] parking there's all these
different things water levels rising you
know I saw this one of these man in the
street things I've been watching that
debt Channel vice you guys watch the
Vice Channel it's a [ __ ] great
Channel reminds me a lot of ways a
little bit of MTV during the early days
were like they had a lot of funny promo
commercials I don't know why more
[ __ ] networks don't do that cuz you
know you usually fast-forward I turn the
channel when there's a commercial but
they got like they have funny [ __ ]
commercials like there's some talk show
on there these two black dudes right at
least one black dude and one guy sort of
Puerto Rican maybe or maybe he's
light-skinned I don't know I'm too white
to understand right so they do a talk
show so they're -
and they show in like the New York City
you know skyline like they always do
before a top show and it was I'm gonna
[ __ ] up the joke it was something like
no big guests no band no audience no
white dudes and then they cut to the
promo and somebody comes out you know I
can't know what the [ __ ] I was watching
I was like this is funny this looks like
way back in the day when I would see
like Randy the Redwoods a gym the taxi
driver you know they would have like
funny promos I don't know why they ever
got away from that but um anyways oh
speaking of that
speaking of non whities
I saw a [ __ ] front man this weekend
in a band that was [ __ ] unbelievable
right I went down the other day I did
the dark matter podcast which is Dave
Navarro's podcast and I had a great time
on that and afterwards they were like
yeah hey Dave's doing his show down at
the Roxy you want to come down Friday
Saturday night I guess he I mean I'm in
the dark here literally no pun intended
I didn't know he did this just Christmas
show every year and it was like an
all-star lineup you don't know who the
[ __ ] coming out and you just go to the
show and then they just start bringing
people out and so I went down there to
go see the show and I mean I knew it was
going to be good dude it was [ __ ]
ridiculous the amount of people that
they had coming out which of course I'm
gonna [ __ ] forget the names and
everything but uh you just you know
someone would come out this guy they
sang the suits saying the immigrant song
and something else it [ __ ] murdered
it I never even heard of the guy [ __ ]
murdered if the band was unbelievable
the viral was killing it and then they
then they brought out Macy Gray and then
she sang the [ __ ] that she sing she's
saying the pretenders brass in pocket
and then she's saying Radiohead creep I
was just like Jesus Christ what the [ __ ]
and then they brought out Cypress Hill
and no one was doing like their own
style of music that everybody would like
switch it up so then they bring out this
they give this [ __ ] intro which no
performer wants to get alright
guy goes to do the intro and he just
goes Billy Morrison was there just
[ __ ] everybody right goes alright
this next guy you know people suggested
him for this show you know first of you
know again you know we don't know we
don't know if he's right for this show
and then we saw him and he absolutely
blew us away our jaws were on the ground
I'm telling you this [ __ ] guy is
unbelievable yada yada and I'm think I
was in the crowd going oh no not that
that intro was the [ __ ] what you
can't follow it it's like in stand-up
comedy this guy he's one of the best
weapon comms today he reinvented the mic
stand start giving you a [ __ ] intro
like that you're just in the back like
guy tone it down
point it down right dude this guy came
out and totally [ __ ] lived up to it
this guy's a rapper I mean I don't know
sure about hip-hop or anything like this
guy post him alone so the guy at states
for whatever reason said this guy's
responsible for Justin Bieber's career
right but I don't know why you would say
that in front of a bunch of [ __ ]
forty to fifty something year old white
people right so this dude comes walking
out and there's a few people bowing like
buh you know like five people because of
the Justin Bieber thing right I love
people in their 40s and 50s who [ __ ]
talk about how bad Justin Bieber's music
is it's like really it doesn't speak to
you
you're [ __ ] dope it's not for you you
know what I mean that's it's like
getting mad at the [ __ ] I don't
insult the guy but you know what I mean
it's it's like it's for younger people
you know what I mean I think hat like I
don't understand people get in their 40s
and 50s and they just they they don't
understand that somebody's perspective
as a 20-something year old is not gonna
seem like the same as theirs and we
sitting there going like what the [ __ ]
is he talking that's like that's
[ __ ] that's a that's a stupid blah
blah blah blah blah it's like yeah yeah
that's what you did when you were there
that age and someday he'll be in his 40s
and a look back at himself at 22 23
going what the [ __ ] was I think
right somehow like four or five people
don't get it they're literally booing
you know Justin Bieber at a show Justin
Bieber isn't at so this guy comes
[ __ ] walking out and he just walks up
to the microphone and he goes what's up
la I'm drunk as [ __ ] right so
immediately the crowd just starts
cheering and he goes I you know I'm
usually you know I'm a rapper
you know everybody I was assuming in the
crowd was like me going like yeah I'm
completely unfamiliar with you I'm a
white guy pushing 50 no idea you are
right so they start playing Rage Against
the Machine killing in the name of and
I'm like going oh god a rappers gonna
sing do they got the auto-tune on you
know is this gonna be like is he gonna
have too much deodorant under his arms
like [ __ ] LL Cool J when he did the
unplugged what's gonna happen here
through this guy this guy [ __ ]
murdered the son [ __ ] murdered this
song don't just took the whole thing to
another level and it never came back
down again everybody else matched this
guy this [ __ ] dude was unbelievably
saying that song and then he's saying
Allison changed wood and [ __ ]
murdered both of them and you literally
felt it in the crowd everybody on their
phones going like who the [ __ ] is this
guy I got a download some of his [ __ ] oh
the his hilarious think so later on that
weekend I'm watching vice and there's
another funny promo he's sitting there
that guy post Malone right now I'm
sitting there with Nia going that's the
[ __ ] guy I saw that's the guy that
murdered that song those two songs right
so he was talking about conspiracy
theory I didn't know what the commercial
was about it was just him talking to
another guy I'm telling he's very like
early days of MTV he was just talking
about conspiracy theory and being able
to teleport and he was just going like
say here's area 51 right which of course
he picks that rather than say in San
Diego okay he goes here's area 51 right
here here's Australia if you want to fly
from area 51 to Australia you got to fly
all the way here you know and indie
draws the arc - we just didn't trust
like someone actually understands
aviation right because this is what
creeped me out because if he just drew a
straight line I'd be like guard this
guy's this guy's out of his mind but the
second he drew the arc I'm like I'll
[ __ ] I'm buying into this theory right
and he goes and he goes what with
teleportation they just do stuff like
this and he just takes the paper and the
X for area 51 was in the expo Australia
is he just takes the paper he just folds
it he pushes him together he goes it's
like that he goes I know you guys think
I'm out of my mind but I know this [ __ ]
is true and I was like this guy's brain
that's what my brain tells me you know
so I I don't know anything about any of
his uh
and he was any of his music but I'm
definitely gonna download some of his
[ __ ] if anybody knows what his best
album is or whatever you know a good
jump off point for that guy it would be
it would be be tremendous so anyways oh
by the way Navarro [ __ ] killed the
guitar solo on that too I was wondering
how the hell he was gonna do it and I
don't know if they came up with a an
effects pedal that made the noise that
the dude from you know [ __ ] Rage
Against the Machine you know cuz he when
he came out here that was those weird
sounds that he made I don't know you
know I was in over my head musically
about [ __ ] 15 minutes ago but
whatever and I want to thank everybody
dark matter for for hooking me up to see
that show it was [ __ ] great man just
a great goddamn show so of course I
talked to Dean Delray who sees
everything he goes oh yeah mana he was I
went to that show at like the fifth
anniversary and it was like [ __ ] Ozzy
Lemmy and Steven Tyler I was just like
oh [ __ ] you man
[ __ ] you're never gonna beat deen
dayal rate with the [ __ ] I went to a
concert story [ __ ] guy seen
everything so anyway so I'm watching
this Vice Channel I know I'm just
plowing through this [ __ ] [ __ ] all
over the place um
and my wife just kept you know recording
this [ __ ] they recorded something about
like DJs
she recorded something about these the
[ __ ] kids of those you know oil
barons or whatever oil money in Saudi
Arabia so watching both of these right
the DJ thing you know it's just
something I'd seen before the show not
much money that they're making in in
Vegas and it was funny though actually
actually actually asking a couple of
them what the future was and a few of
them understood it and a few whom just
like yeah it's never gonna end
it's like dude at some point you're
gonna be the BG's in January of 1980 it
happens to all genres of music and in
the so few bands figure out how to do
what how to age gracefully from one ERA
to another and like I was saying like
yeah I think I was talking about that I
don't came on what [ __ ] podcast is
you have to say I don't know how to do
it but somehow you have to like your
music has to age with you so you don't
look like a [ __ ] [ __ ] like Justin
Bieber has got to write some [ __ ]
middle-aged [ __ ] when he's in his middle
age you know because he can't be singing
about whatever the whatever the [ __ ] he
sings about you know I'm you look stupid
at 40 you know and it makes everybody in
the crowd feels old then you saw my God
we're gonna die you know you just see
your mortality when they come up
I mean first time that I saw that was
when I like ten years ago when David Lee
Roth came back with Van Halen and I went
to go see van Halen I was like oh my god
this is gonna be [ __ ] great right I
can't believe he's back
I saw Diamond Dave went on the eat him
and smile tours gonna be easily thrown
you know just think he's gonna throw in
[ __ ] kicks and jump it off the stage
till the the [ __ ] split right and
dude he came walking out on stage and I
swear it within two hours I know my god
and like look at five seconds like oh
[ __ ]
he sold I'm old we're gonna die
not here and I get like this wave of
[ __ ] depression just hit me you know
until I really realized like wait a
minute
like you know guitarists and drummers
don't get old I mean they do but like
you know they can still [ __ ] you know
if they have a technique or whatever
they can still [ __ ] still [ __ ]
shred and I forgot that Eddie and Alex
have been playing again for like 50
[ __ ] years and they were unbelievable
the singer has it the worst because your
voice naturally drops and of course
everyone from my era actually [ __ ]
sang you know not to [ __ ] on Justin
Bieber boy when I was watching that DJ
thing on the Vice Channel
they [ __ ] he shows up at some some
pool party you know where everybody's
[ __ ] you know turning their cameras
around doing selfies in the peace sign
and the duck lips and all that [ __ ] and
he shows up to sing his song and he's
just clearly [ __ ] lip-syncing he's
not even trying to do a good job and
everybody's freaking out
there was a few times like he took the
mic away from his mouth pointed at the
crowd he could still hear him singing
and nobody gave a [ __ ] there was no band
there was nothing and all these Yolo
douches were going [ __ ] nuts it's
like how is that acceptable I don't know
that that [ __ ] makes me feel old like
back in the day if you ever got caught
Milli Vanilli oh the whole [ __ ] he
milli milli and Vanilli do his whole
[ __ ] way through that nobody gave a
[ __ ] to one 20 30 [ __ ] years earlier
you know I guess it's cuz those guys
technically never even sang on the track
I don't know everybody's doing [ __ ]
commercials now I mean it's just back
and it's the whole thing has just
changed you just do whatever you want
you don't have to sing you can [ __ ]
you know you can lip-sync your way with
your hit song through a commercial for
[ __ ] underoos and it actually equates
to more album downloads evidently I
should just be sitting on a porch right
now watching young people walking by
yelling at up that's what this podcast
is just slowly becoming so anyways I'm
watching that channel and the next thing
Nia recorded was this
thing about the it looked like those
same guys that I saw when I was in
London
the Middle Eastern dudes who fly on a
cargo plane fly in all their [ __ ]
cars with this same ridiculous rap you
know well maybe it's a paint job I think
it's a rap that they put on there you
know what I mean they got like the
[ __ ] it's like that marriage finish
like those three people in China now
with the gold suits they'll do that too
like Mercedes and all that well when
they're back in that country another
status symbol is to own a like
endangered species or exotic animals as
they call them and these [ __ ] guys
they owned like cheetahs and lions and
tigers
it was the most disturbing [ __ ] thing
and I might be coming with this and like
a PETA way I just set that going like
dude that is a [ __ ] lion you got it
on a leash and these things kept you
know they have their friends over and
they'd sort of lunge at them and then
friends would jump out of the way be
like whoa laughing it's just like if you
saw how big these [ __ ] things were
it's just like they could like sort of
like it they've 30% like bitch-slap a
refrigerator and the thing would tip
over and go flying across the [ __ ]
room you know what I mean
and these guys are [ __ ] teasing so
this [ __ ] lady goes over there this
white lady making white people look look
[ __ ] stupid as [ __ ] she's like she
[ __ ] goes over to this guy's goddamn
house he's got a giant [ __ ] lion
alright he goes well we'll get or a
tiger or some [ __ ] he goes all right
we'll get you comfortable we'll let you
play with some smaller ones first so
she's playing with these little ones and
immediately I said I wouldn't [ __ ] with
that a long time ago I was on Opie and
Anthony they brought in a [ __ ] baby
tiger a little ones little white ones or
some [ __ ] and they asked me if they
wanted a hole if I wanted to hold it I
was like no the thing was upset it
didn't want to [ __ ] be there and I've
been scratched by a housecat [ __ ]
killed right now all I got me with one
goddamn claw went right down my forearm
I had to put all this [ __ ] on it so I
wouldn't get some sort of goddamned
ZZZ and I'm looking at this this cute
little baby tiger a lion whatever the
[ __ ] it was no Siegfried and Roy once
the Mariah Carey one where it's all
[ __ ] white you know and I'm just
looking at the size of its [ __ ] paws
I'm like that thing's paws already a
like four times the size of a house cat
I've got scratched by a house cat this
thing's in a bad mood I don't want to
[ __ ] I want to deal with the thing you
know what's funny he's actually
scratched Anthony if I remember
correctly and he had to get like a
tetanus shot or something some sort of
point meant and to be put on his [ __ ]
neck so anyway so this lady goes in
there right and she's playing with them
she's like oh my god there's sort
durable and was really not impressed
with the intellect of the woman I
thought they could have got somebody a
lot [ __ ] smarter right so then she
goes outside to meet this lion okay this
lioness and there's no way to describe
to you how big a [ __ ] lion is it's
not very often that you get to see a
person standing next to a goddamn lion
she walks up to the general area they're
saying the things immediately looking at
her the way a [ __ ] wild animal looks
at you you know what I mean it's the
same way I've always said this it's the
same way like a [ __ ] hooker looks at
you where it's no [ __ ] you know you
don't know bar some woman looks at you
you know to and you fall you know she's
just trying to get a [ __ ] drink
the hooker looks at you it's a real deal
like yeah I will [ __ ] you okay if the
circumstances are you know if you got
the money I will [ __ ] you right it's the
same thing with like lines they looking
at you like if the opportunity arises I
will kill you you know dogs don't look
at you like that [ __ ] Lions look you
know cats attempt it house cats you know
you turn around you catch them stalking
you and [ __ ]
but then you look at them and then they
[ __ ] run away alright picture a cat
doing that a house cat but you turn
around and it's a lion and it doesn't
run away it [ __ ] lunges at you or
maybe gives you that refrigerator
bitch-slap right so this [ __ ] thing
is looking at her and he's the owner who
has no training whatsoever brings
[ __ ] thing I'll do my palms were like
sweaty I had to get where I was watching
it in bed I literally stood up going
what the [ __ ] are you doing so the thing
comes over immediately starts crawling
on top of her it's on top of her and
then she puts her hands on the side of
the thing and starts like like you know
rubbing it like it's a giant dog and all
I remember was that there's a youtube
video of that stuntman who worked with
bears and he had brought his some sort
of relative in there who wanted to learn
how to work with bears and he told to
keep his hands down by his side and the
bear came up and like stood up on its
back legs put its paws on the dudes
shoulder and he instinctively put his
hands on either side of the bear which
the bear took as like an aggressive move
and wanted to fight and it [ __ ]
killed this guy so she puts her hands
there and I see that I go I'll [ __ ] is
this thing like a bear I don't [ __ ]
know and all of a sudden she got just a
little bit scared and then the thing
like collapsed down on her and it got
weird really quick and then the guy
stood up with this rope [ __ ] leash
and like quickly tries to pull the lion
away which she does and this woman gets
up like hahaha that was hell looks like
it's I feel like that was like a
spiritual experience Avella that's like
[ __ ] woman's got [ __ ] killed and
then the guy goes yeah you got scared
and it senses your fear and then of God
thank God she didn't make any
high-pitched noise like the sound of an
animal like suffering you know I mean
you ever hear like a dog toy you know
when they bite on it and it makes that
high-pitched noise it excites the
predator and him and so I say to Mia I
go how far were did this show before
they show us somebody who get killed I
go I say about 17 minutes they didn't it
was at the end of the show and they were
just like two weeks after we left this
[ __ ] woman basically the housekeeper
comes in all right she didn't [ __ ] do
anything she's not like these [ __ ]
guys who for some reason like it's it's
just total like male ego [ __ ] trying to
outdo the other [ __ ] rich guy down
the street that they get these things
they don't know anything
about the animals they [ __ ] at least
that's the way it was presented they
didn't know [ __ ] about the [ __ ]
animals and then they were like now the
thing has a better life living here it's
walking around in a [ __ ] cage you
know it's like dude would you want to
walk around in a cage I mean you could
always get knifed you could get killed
the same way an animal couldn't in the
wild
it's a [ __ ] lion who's killing a lion
other than another human being so
anyways this [ __ ] housekeeper came in
and she got mauled by these [ __ ]
lions and they bring the woman in and
the guy tried to say a dog did it and
they were like these injuries are a
little more than a dog and then the
owner is like well whatever do you mean
it's like well she's missing her left
arm and the claw marks on this and he so
you know what the [ __ ] [ __ ] did he
had three lions he went home he shot all
of them and then burned their bodies out
in the desert so he you know so nothing
would [ __ ] happen to him and it was
just like yes I can't there you go there
you go [ __ ] inevitable they had like
cheetahs this guy's riding in a [ __ ]
six wheeled Mercedes with the [ __ ]
cheetah and that woman's getting in the
car going oh it's it's it's acting just
like a dog it's panting it's looking out
the window maybe they had to get
somebody I'm not saying she was not a
smart person she just wasn't very aware
of the situation I feel and I just kept
hearing like it was back in the day like
50 Def Jam comics did bits about how
white people [ __ ] with wild animals and
so in a way I'm like oh this is good for
once it's not white people being idiots
with wild animals you know now it's
Arabs let's let's you know take a little
heat off a whitey and then they bring
this white lady in there and she [ __ ]
does everything that you know every one
of those bits says that we do so anyways
let's get to some of the some of the
reads here for the week if I can if my
[ __ ] computer isn't going to tell me
to [ __ ] I don't know update something
oh jesus here we go
here we go wait I have to promote this
thing real quick all right I was
supposed to promote this regular hero
year-in-review you could donate now and
be a regular hero to change a life today
these people work around the world to
help the disadvantaged they they are
another yet another nonprofit and I'm
assuming that because it's on my podcast
that this is a this is actually a legit
one you know they help out with
Hurricane Matthew Skid Row at-risk youth
Oh regular heroes show oh [ __ ] I've done
one of these oh this is what's this
Steve Simone thing right the regular
hero show has been a great fun and
awareness raiser thanks to comedians
bill bird Gabriel Iglesias Dane Cook
Daniel Tosh Chris Hardwick Chris D'Elia
the world at the world-famous Comedy
Store in the improv yeah this is
actually legit one you know in a world
where so many these nonprofits are a
complete horseshit this is actually a
legit one which is a very nice thing
because everything's a [ __ ]
non-profit like you remember that that
that Leigh from a couple months back she
she lost a job at that non-profit yet
another non-profit when she said that
horrible [ __ ] about Michelle Obama you
know and of course wrote it like a dope
she said something like it will be so
refreshing to have a classy beautiful
dignified first lady in the White House
you mean that trophy wife what cuz she
wears a red blouse all of a sudden she's
[ __ ] a you know a better person she
wrote I'm tired of seeing ape in heels
not an aan ape in heels and ape is
capitalized like it's I don't know
somebody's name or some [ __ ] like that
and so of course she gets [ __ ] she
gets bounced out of this nonprofit she
gets fired cuz everybody knows that
makes you less racist you're racist and
then you lose your job
then you go oh wait a minute what was I
thinking everybody is equal
so anyways then the the [ __ ] mayor
from this town Clay County is something
in Virginia Virginia West Virginia
I guess backed up her goddamn uh why you
would do that you know even if you were
races you think you'd be smart enough to
keep your [ __ ] mouth shut this person
co-signed and what the other person said
and then the mayor had to [ __ ] resign
so anyways they actually so they fired
the first lady who said it from the Clay
County Development Corporation nonprofit
they're a corporation that developed
[ __ ] and then but it's not for profit
well let me ask you this how is this
woman not homeless I don't get how you
work for a non-profit and you're not
homeless if there's no profit how do
they pay you this is what all
corporations do I'm in business I'm in
business with a certain corporation that
claims a ninety to a hundred and eighty
million dollar loss a year and the
people I work with are buying mansions
out here redoing them I don't know how
that works
that's actually a different thing
because they're not considered a
nonprofit they're considered a business
entity and if you don't show that you've
earned any money then you don't have to
pay any taxes so the corporation doesn't
but then everybody draws a salary now
you have to pay taxes on when the salary
that you drew but however if you just
say you're not making a profit you don't
have to pay any taxes and I would think
that all that extra money that you
didn't pay taxes on you then just
dispersed amongst your employees right
so rather than making a million a year
you make two million a year and then you
pay taxes on that right I don't know how
it works I don't know you know I'm too
stupid to figure out how that [ __ ] works
but for the life of me I looked up this
nonprofit trying to figure out what the
[ __ ] they do I cannot I can't figure it
out so anyways they fired this [ __ ]
lady and pretend like a month later they
just reinstated her they just reinstated
her
uh I don't to me that is the Trump
influence I think that that's what
everybody learned from Trump it's just
like you just say hey you know that's
locker room talk or uh you know alright
he's fired because Becca yeah you know
I'm back yeah you know I left for six
weeks and I'm back you know and what
what I love in with media is there's no
follow-up after the first story the
first story's done this is the whole
[ __ ] everybody flipping out let's go
burn the witch and then once it dies
down then you just bring the person back
and no but they're they've moved on to
something else I don't know it's really
bizarre I just don't know how somebody
could [ __ ] be in business with
somebody like that it's [ __ ] nuts
anyways alright me undies
oh Jesus but oh boo me undies me undies
rubbing up on your [ __ ] we do do do me
undies me undies it's like a sheepskin
[ __ ] sock it's so [ __ ] soft up
against your taint you know you [ __ ]
love it you dick you will paints with a
pair of [ __ ] me undies why would you
paint your dick I don't know how many
[ __ ] times can I sing this picture a
world in a world we're putting on a new
pair of underwear isn't just fresh
you're stepping into a better day you
know I bet wears me undies Oh lives in
the undies lifestyle is Mariah Carey I
know it's the second time I brought her
up but that [ __ ] channel Mia keeps
watching I don't one of these reality
shows that's following Mariah Carey
around dude she's [ __ ] hilarious
every [ __ ] shot she's like laying in
a bed in an evening gown with heels on
full makeup and everything with a glass
of wine it's like in the 1950s what
people thought rich people did all day
just laying around with like you know
some [ __ ] $300,000 diamond necklace
it's like we get it you're a diva Jesus
Christ you never wear sweatpants you
know just have a [ __ ] white zinfandel
over there anyways it says think about
it underwear it's the first thing you
put on the last thing you take off
unless you weird you know what if you
don't like your torso what if you're one
of those guys that [ __ ] with this shirt
on you know
your sweaty t-shirt with yeah right you
know what I mean he's still a good
t-shirt off you know ladies if you're
[ __ ] a guy who has man tits that's
when you know he's really letting you
win is when he takes the t-shirt off -
oh jesus but why would you say that all
right think about it underwear it's for
a moment why would you settle for
anything less than the best feelin
underwear on the planet me undies
focuses solely on producing the most
comfortable underwear you've ever
experienced
my friends at me undies sent me a few
pairs a while back and now I can't
imagine wearing anything else why do you
keep putting on the copy you sent me two
pairs I wore them one I liked the other
with a Greg Louganis cut and I don't
that wasn't in that shape you know you
sent me the Olympic diver [ __ ]
skivvies there you know Jesus Christ
I went from muffin top to like I don't
know what the [ __ ] course aunt what's
the next one up the pastry ladder
it really makes each day that much
better for the price of two cocktails me
undies will deliver your new favorite
pair of underwear right to your doorstep
better day guarantee you try them on and
if they got the most comfortable best
feelin underwear you've ever have had
they'll refund you and let you keep your
first pair for free well obviously what
are you gonna take it back like that
[ __ ] mattress company these uber cozy
undies are sold exclusively on the
undies website where you'll enjoy free
shipping in the US and Canada and for a
limited time everyone in my audience
gets 20% off their first order but you
have to order our go to our special URL
me undies dot-com / / to get 20% off
that's my undies dot-com / / alright
give me Luke rate everybody hey nerds
wake the [ __ ] up here we go be the envy
of your friends and get your 100%
exclusive crates at Luke rate calm / /
and enter my code birth to save three
dollars off any new subscription what
the [ __ ] is a Luke rate oh here we go
wait until I tell wait until I tell you
suppose we excited here wait wait until
I tell you about December's great it'll
have you fight the power
loot crate offers an epic range of
pop-culture items for less than $20 a
month if you're more of a fanatical
fashionista than try loot where monthly
wearables and accessories with Koch
classics and your favorite franchises if
you want to get fancy get a bigger box
and even bigger loop with Lou Craig dx1
a geek out your pet try loop pets offer
expires December 19th at 9 p.m. Pacific
get ready for December's rebellious
themed revolution they're always
watching I have no idea what any of this
[ __ ] is but I know nerds are loving this
they designed a system to keep you down
and their meddlesome hello friends it's
time for a revolution december's Craig
features exclusive items from assassin's
creed no mr. robot holy [ __ ]
Firefly our monthly t-shirt and pin and
more including an exclusive Funko pop
I'm telling you I say this every week
that sounds like a [ __ ] dad gene Band
Funko pop we take elements of funk you
know we like really into Tower of Power
it's like a James Brown kind of thing
and we met we mash it we do it one of
the kids call it a [ __ ] combining
there of two songs with the same tempo
of more contemporary things our kids
love it
do not wait you have until the 19th at 9
p.m. Pacific hey maybe next year when
Navarro does a show maybe you'll have
some members of Funko pop come on
Pacific to subscribe to for December's
crate when is when it's over it's over
no more crates go to loot crate calm
slash burn enter my code birth to save
three dollars off any new subscription
today how many more [ __ ] things are
there no I don't know read on this
alright guys can you handle one more can
I just do one more just to [ __ ] plow
through this [ __ ] alright now that you
know how to dress like a nerd now that
your balls are nice and soft you know at
some point you're gonna want a sandwich
right blue apron everybody not to be
confused with red apron this is blue
apron this is for the Democrats only
alright not all not
if you want to cry into your meal after
Trump gets sworn in you got to go to
blue apron not all ingredients are
created equal fresh high-quality
ingredients make a real difference so
it's important to know where your food
comes from talk about how blue [ __ ] you
I'll talk about what I want to talk
about affordable for less than $10 per
person per meal blue apron delivers
seasonal recipes along with pre portion
ingredients to make delicious
home-cooked meal variety we got you
covered
choose from a variety of new recipes
each week or let blue aprons culinary
team surprise you holy [ __ ] is that corn
flakes recipes are not repeated with any
years you'll never get bored you like
Mariah Carey every [ __ ] time she's
got a different one flexible customize
your recipes each week based on your
preferences blue apron has several
delivery options so you can choose what
fits your needs and there's no weekly
commitment so you only get deliveries
when you want them easy you want it easy
you don't want to thank you [ __ ] dope
here we go each meal comes from with a
step-by-step easy-to-follow recipe card
card and pre-portioned ingredients and
can be prepared in 40 minutes or less
just like Rachael Ray over there
guaranteed blue aprons freshness
freshness guarantees promises that every
ingredient you deliver Lee arrives ready
to cook they'll make it right check out
this week's menu and get the first three
meals for free with free shipping by
going to blue apron Cobb slash bar
you'll love how good it feels
and taste you create incredible
home-cooked meals of blue apron so don't
wait that's blue apron comp / / blue
apron a better way to cook why do we
write so much [ __ ] copy it's like you
I get it I get it
okay I get all these aren't all cool
some of these are Reed's I [ __ ] up I
only have one left oh my god this is
great there's only one left everybody
then I get into the questions for the
week perfect all right SeatGeek everyone
buying tickets online for sports and
concert has been a confusing process for
a long time yes it has it's always been
hard to find the best deal for that game
or show you want to go to and none of
those older ticket sites want to change
that but see geek is different they've
come along and created an amazing app
and website that makes it easier for
every fan to buy and sell tickets
everything about sea geek is
designed to make life easier for sports
and music fancy keek does all the price
comparisons for you by searching
multiple ticket sites and ensuring that
you get the best possible deal see keek
does all the work and you save time and
money best of all my listeners get $20
$20 rebate off their first SeatGeek
purchase to get you $20 rebate on
tickets download the SeatGeek
app go to the settings tab and click on
the add a promo code allow them to
access all your photos and to track you
long after you've bought the seats enter
promo code beside this is an uber enter
promo code burp see keek will send you
$20 after you've made your first ticket
purchase download the Sikhi cap and
enter the promo code birt'day alrighty
then
alright so according to the emails
somebody wanted me to look at this
[ __ ] thing and it simply says crazy
asian sport saw this on reddit neat and
needed you to see it
Merry Christmas twinkle eyes alright
let's see what this is oh my god
alright let me hit pause here this is
basically this is alright there's this
whole group of [ __ ] dudes they're all
dressed in white oh my god they were all
huddled around a pole and there's a guy
sitting on top of the [ __ ] pole and
then another group of dudes come in
wearing orange shirts and the [ __ ]
they all have on like Olympic boxing
headgear and that when the [ __ ]
orange dudes come in they're trying to
knock the guy off the pole this is like
[ __ ] ants fighting each other dude
you [ __ ] [ __ ] how can you show me
this and not tell me what sport this is
they try to knock the guy off the
[ __ ] pole what is this called and
what happens is basically everybody gets
piled on once the orange crew comes in
oh there's a weak guy he turned he ran
the other [ __ ] way they start jumping
up on top of each other oh my god I
would be so [ __ ] claustrophobic it's
basically like a rugby scrum
if you could throw [ __ ] punches and
you climb in just imagine a rugby scrum
and rather than the ball one of the
rugby dudes was sitting up on a pole and
they're trying to [ __ ] knock him off
wow dude they're just kicking each other
in the face I swear to god you know how
the [ __ ] that I get so lucky to be born
in this goddamn country where they at
least pretend to give a [ __ ] about your
well-being and you like that is a
[ __ ] hardcore sport you know what
hats off the [ __ ] Asia right there I
would love to see them try to get this
is barbaric you know trying to do it in
our country like everybody's listening
from America my country I should say
this is barbaric this is this is
promoting violence against people with
different kinds of shirts odd I mean I
don't even understand what is it what is
the purpose of this can you please tell
me the name of that sport am I ever
gonna get over this [ __ ] cough
haven't smoked a cigar in forever I'm
getting eight hours sleep
not really you know Nia's tossing a turn
on every [ __ ] minute now
I literally you know I I I sleep in bed
for like half the night and then after a
while I just ended up going upstairs and
I fall asleep you know I don't do the
same thing like when the baby comes I'm
just gonna be when the baby cries too
much I'm just gonna be like you know
what I can't deal with either one of you
and I'm gonna go upstairs and I'm gonna
put on an evening gown like Mariah Carey
and and lay here with my [ __ ]
diamonds on I don't know maybe it's just
for the show but I just look at it as
like this person is out of their fingers
at some point it's just completely lost
touch of reality there's something about
that when you get like backup dancers
and they're all hanging on your every
word and they and they literally want to
be you like there's no way to keep keep
yourself tethered to any sort of [ __ ]
reality
alright advice age different story first
of all did I talk about everything I
wanted to [ __ ] talk about this week
oh let's talk about how you guys doing
with you Katya
if you late to the podcast you can still
start right now man I've been trying to
do a half-hour cardio every single day
because this you know between
Thanksgiving
and uh New Year's she eat all of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] you put on weight then you
gotta just start the year behind the
eight ball by the eight ball right I was
like I'm not [ __ ] doing that so as of
December 1st I've been trying to do
cardio a half-hour cardio every single
[ __ ] day and of course I [ __ ] up
right
I what did I do it through the first 11
days and then December 12th I had a busy
morning and you really got to knock it
out in the morning which I didn't and
the day got longer and longer and then I
came home Nia was watching some [ __ ]
TV and she's just like I need comfort
and I was just like all right acting
like I was a good husband rather than
like I don't get on that [ __ ]
elliptical again so I missed a half hour
on the 12th 13th I did my half hour so I
had 12 out of 13 days 14th
I missed then I was like [ __ ] this is
becoming a trend now I owe that machine
down there
60 minutes plus the 30 for today that
was Friday December 15th so I got on
that elliptical baa baa red cakes I got
on the thing and I did an hour and 11
minutes 71 minutes out of the 90 minutes
I just looked at it like it was a
basketball game or a sporting event I
was down by 90 points and so the next
day I started my day I was down 19
points plus the 30 I had to do and I
ended up doing an hour on the elliptical
so now I was up 11 minutes and then I
liked it I liked the results of doing a
[ __ ] hour so then on say I did an
hour and four minutes so then now I'm up
I was down 90 minutes now I was up an
hour and 15 also known as 75 minutes and
then yesterday I did an hour and 15
minutes so I don't know what I'm up at
this point
45 minutes plus the next to 45 I'm
actually up 90 minutes something like
that I don't know what the [ __ ] it is I
can't really remember but all I wanted
to do I was going to do a half hour
every day
and that was gonna be so 31 days that
would be 15 and a half hours of cardio
but uh now I think I'm just gonna do
hours every day for the rest of the
[ __ ] year I wait myself the other day
I was 177 now when I came back from
[ __ ] Europe I was a buck 90 so I've
taken 13 pounds off since since that
trip so I don't know it's all about the
[ __ ] cardio I would love to do that
you know if I if you don't the reality
is if you got an elliptical every day
and did [ __ ] 60 minutes if you just
did that you know and when you do that
when you put together a playlist that's
when you gotta love I tell you you got a
love like bands like Iron Maiden well
they have six seven minute songs you
know at least them the songs are at
least four minutes which is a huge
[ __ ] chunk you know and I just put my
sweatshirt over the clock and I'm just
like I just peeked at the clock after
every songs done alright so if you're
just doing a half hour of cardio you
gotta listen to it's a 13 minutes you
know right you listen the whole [ __ ]
thing the curse is the apart right
you're gonna go from [ __ ] 27 minutes
down to 14 minutes see like just a
[ __ ] joke I always try to put it on
you know have it come on time it with
like 21 minutes you know and then I just
cover it up because the next time I look
I'm gonna be in single digits I'll be
done in like 8 or 9 minutes
it's [ __ ] tremendous but uh anyways I
a buddy of mine my drum teacher was
showing me this [ __ ] song this week
and I don't know how I slept on this
where I've always been a big Soundgarden
fan and somehow I never heard that song
rhino sore and as always mat came and
with the sickest [ __ ] drums I've
become obsessed with that song and that
[ __ ] album and when I saw it I
thought it said 2016 I was like oh they
got back together this is their latest
[ __ ] and then I looked again and said
every [ __ ] thing that I listen to I
don't know what happened me I think part
of it was I got old and then I was also
like trying to [ __ ] get somewhere as
a comedian I just completely missed out
on like 20 years of music and like half
the [ __ ] people show me I'm like that
sounds [ __ ] you know it always sounds
like it's brand-new to me when that come
out and they're like yeah like 2002 I'm
like yeah I just I just can't get
contemporary I got 20 years of [ __ ] I
got a [ __ ] sit through so if there's
any other drums out there you know part
of my lessons is they'll play [ __ ] at
the end like ear training [ __ ] like you
got to try to figure out the groove you
got are you gonna figure out what time
signature was in and this was to figure
out what time signature was in and of
course I was [ __ ] it up and a few
drummers out there it's in six but if
you count the eighth notes you just
count up to 12 and the phrasing is seven
and five and I would play it for you on
here but I always just feel like because
I do advertising if I play any music
then all of a sudden somebody's gonna
come after me be like you owe us money
cuz you made money off of me on DS while
you played our [ __ ] song or whatever
anyways what do you guys think of the
Patriots yesterday
everybody's flipping out about our
defense like I don't know what the big
you know we beat the Ravens and the
Ravens that yeah you know there's they
got that sub sky but back and they they
had Suggs they had Ray Lewis and they
had Ed Reed so their big three is
basically down to one dude and you know
they're not who the [ __ ] they were and
then we beat the Broncos in Mile High
where we never [ __ ] with but they
basically enable get got a rookie
quarterback I don't know I get so
frustrated with the Patriots because it
seems like they only protect their own
offensive players they but I know I've
been bitching about this but they just
you know that [ __ ] cornerback
whatever the [ __ ] his name is taalib
whatever [ __ ] his name is like he when
he was with us that then whole side of
his whole squadron section of the field
was just shut down
what didn't we like about that why do we
just keep that guy you know we always we
got [ __ ] wide receivers we got [ __ ]
got quarterback that's what we keep all
that [ __ ] we you know what this is my
theory Bill Belichick is such a
defensive genius I think he just thinks
like you know what I don't [ __ ] need
uh you know I don't I don't look at this
my [ __ ] computer just decided you
know I said act you know contact me in
an hour now it's like all right and
hours gone by now it's just syncing with
my [ __ ] phone
like who's doing this so weird it's like
all these [ __ ] satellites just
[ __ ] pointed at ya I don't know
anyways I think he just is convinced
that he can take any second-round draft
pick train this person into being a NFL
quality player at that position slash
borderline all-pro few and if you become
an all-pro then he just [ __ ] gets
Rydia the second you want money just
[ __ ] been doing it forever by back in
the day you know we keep McGinnis we
kept Rabil so our defense I felt like
had an identity now it's like every
three years it's like a whole new
[ __ ] defense it drives me up the
[ __ ] wall
I don't know we'll see because I watched
the Giants you know and you know like
all Patriot fans every year when the
Giants go on their run you get this
sickening feeling in your stomach going
like ah [ __ ] yeah you want to play him
again cuz we got to beat him one time
you know and I was sitting there going
like alright well they lost Tom Coughlin
this is gonna be huge and lo and behold
they're doing it again they're on
another [ __ ] run alright you know the
defense looks [ __ ] amazing you know
I'm not saying that defense doesn't look
good but it does not look as good as
theirs and I don't know that's the
Giants thing like the only thing about
the Giants is they don't score any
[ __ ] points for whatever [ __ ]
reason they got Eli who's a goddamn
beast they got the [ __ ] they got the
diva there what's his name how do I tell
my short-term memories for [ __ ] I just
thought Wyatt
I kept [ __ ] rub his last names the
same name is the [ __ ] soccer player
with all the tattoos is married to the
spice girl back up Bend It Like Beckham
Odell Beckham there you go
see that I'm learning on my [ __ ] old
brain works no I got to go on one of
those brain exercise websites that try
to help you with your short-term memory
I don't know I'm fascinated how they can
have him at wide receiver you know I
don't know if they're playing that
cruise guy a bunch of [ __ ] money but
they got Eli they're able to keep him
but then on the other side of the ball
they got jpp and if he didn't [ __ ]
mess up his hand like they seemed eight
they're more balanced you know so what
if Chandler Jones wanted money he
[ __ ] earned it sometimes I just feel
like we're getting I don't what the [ __ ]
you build well how many Super Bowls do
they have to win before you realize Bill
Belichick knows what he's doing I know I
know I'm just looking at the NFC West
and it just seems like this stronger
I'll tell you right now I'm selling I
don't believe in him I don't believe in
the Dallas Cowboys I don't believe in a
coach I don't know about you know this
is just totally based on I look at that
guy and I go I don't I don't believe in
that guy I just don't Pete Carroll is a
[ __ ] beast
eli is an animal and their coach who i
swear to god looks like he won some
radio contest is is a is a wolf in
sheep's clothing is a wolf and upperdeck
[ __ ] eating a pretzel get mustard all
over his face clothing I think one of
those teams and this is really isn't
going out on a limb I think one of those
two teams goes to the to the Super Bowl
and having watched both teams I think I
would rather play I'd rather play
Seattle and that's only because Seattle
you know once you went a couple you went
to win a Super Bowl you go to back to
back you know they lost too many guys
not to say that they couldn't beat the
Patriots there they [ __ ] beat us this
year but uh we'll see we'll see I never
[ __ ] believe in my team you know what
I mean I don't know why I always just
see the [ __ ] you know why are we
doing this why are we doing that
so anyways we shall see but uh be nice
to play the Giants again and finally
[ __ ] win we actually would have to
win that game or else
Tom Brady would forever just get ripped
on sports talk radio while his mouth
breathing dopes they would be like like
it was this one-on-one game like Tom
Brady every Super Bowl has not led his
team down the field for the winning
score he's had to do that every Super
Bowl that he's been in you know and four
out of six times the defense went out
and did their job and two times they did
not and I'm not taking it away from
[ __ ] Eli because two times
Eli beat our defense but he beat our
defense he did not beat Tom Brady
however when you're the quarterback you
take all the Brant blame you know all
you got to do is look at Dan Marino and
the ridiculous level of [ __ ] that that
guy takes despite the fact all the
records that that guy I I've never
understood it it's just did he have to
tackle people too was he supposed to run
the ball up the gut to [ __ ] eat up
some of the clock I don't know right
it's just so [ __ ] this [ __ ] that Dan
Marino gets it's the dumbest it's the
dumbest ever this is how much the game
has changed by the way I look this up
the other day just because all they do
is [ __ ] throw the ball and I looked
up all time you know running backs just
rushing all time for your career and
I'll tell you right now what's-his-face
Emmitt Smith no one's gonna break that
[ __ ] record the way the way they just
don't run the [ __ ] ball anymore no
one's gonna get anywhere near that thing
let me look this [ __ ] up like I looked
it up yesterday and not now I don't know
install these [ __ ] things [ __ ] off
Jesus Christ it's like a [ __ ] kid
tugging at you mammy mammy mammy
we got all-time NFL rushers
all right where the [ __ ] is it pro
football reference this is the best
thing ever so I look this [ __ ] up okay
and in the top 20 top 20 alt like as of
right now there's only three active
players in the top 20 the first seven
are all retired okay the the highest
ranking one is Frank Gore who has 12,000
931 yards all right then you got to go
all the way down to 16 you got Adrian
Peterson who granted took a year off
because he beat his kids up with with
something fun in the woods Adrian
Peterson and then he got Steven Jackson
at 18 all right you go to the all-time
where the [ __ ] is it passing where the
hell is it passing yards how hard is it
to find that pass saying yards all right
so there's only there's only there's
only three active players top 20 rushing
right starts at 8 and ends at 18 all
right
passing all time there's in the top 14
there's six active players six active
players in the top 14 all time there's
only eight other cubies in the history
of the NFL that is thrown as many or
more yards than six current [ __ ]
players and the top two all-time are
Peyton Manning and Brett Favre Peyton
Manning just retired last year Brett
Favre retired six years ago it's [ __ ]
unbelievable like how much this game has
changed and there's only two really old
school names in the top 20 is Johnny
Unitas where's the other one in Fran
Tarkenton and once what's his face like
John Elway warren moon that class Dan
Fouts Joe Montana
they came in they did their damage to
Kerry Collins is in the [ __ ]
he's sixteenth all-time so here you go
so you got Peyton Manning's one Brett
Favre is to Drew Brees is three with
65,000 462 yards he's less than 7,000
yards
let's 106 six thousand five hundred
yards away from owning the record Dan
Marino's fourth then it's Tom Brady John
Elway Warren Moon then Eli Manning is 8
then Fran Tarkenton then Ben
Roethlisberger Vinny Testaverde Philip
Rivers Drew Bledsoe Carson Palmer Dan
Fouts I've seen like everybody all of
these people play in my lifetime I did
catch the end of Fran Tarkenton Dan
Fouts Kerry Collins Joe Montana Johnny
Unitas I didn't see Dave Craig Boomer
Esiason Donovan McNabb all right Don
McManus is 21st all-time that's how much
the [ __ ] game has changed it's it's
unbelievable and what it is is that
these guys are like throwing for four
yards five six yards that [ __ ] used to
give to the running back so I think
Emmitt Smith Walter Payton those guys no
one's gonna touch their fighter and I
don't know how you get enough [ __ ]
attempts to even do it was there a point
to that bill um yeah they throw the ball
a lot I guess that's what I'm saying Jim
Irsay completely chained and then
nothing to is just the way that they
protect the [ __ ] quarterbacks you
know when they call it the Tom Brady
rule because that time he turned around
and looked at the referee said hey
referee was like oh I'm sorry [ __ ]
threw the flag yeah everybody calls it
the Tom Brady rule which I love I love
that they call it the Tom Brady rule
because it is you know you got to
protect your quarterbacks that's your
money everybody realizes that yeah you
know when when the best you know
everybody knows the [ __ ] quarterback
that guy gets knocked out no one's gonna
watch the game so they protect the hell
out of them and they're like yeah [ __ ]
everybody else and people who not into
sports they're into offense they want to
see some action so they just they you
know now it's like illegal to cover
[ __ ] to cover a [ __ ] receiver you
know Duke Dan Marino did the [ __ ] you
could do during that guy's [ __ ]
career when he's still through for like
60,000 [ __ ] yards I don't know
I always talk about steroids right and
they put an asterisk next to your name
you know they don't you don't have the
same way they don't give Barry Bonds
it's just - it's just like you gonna sit
there and tell me you know all of these
[ __ ] guys were as good as Dan Marino
with the yards they're putting up [ __ ]
out of here all right advice age
difference in history dear bill I'm just
a bill yes I'm only a bill I'm a big fan
of yours I really enjoy your podcast
you'll thank you very much I appreciate
I am 28 years old and in a relationship
with my girlfriend who's 7 years younger
than me and who I plan on marrying we're
really great together I love her well
congratulations the thing is is as our
relationship has gone on we've slash
I've been getting some static from
people about our relationship well who
gives a [ __ ] what they think like I said
she's seven years younger than me but
we've known each other for a while
we've met when I was working at my first
job as a counselor at a camp when she
was one of the kids oh Jesus when we
first met I was 17 and she was 10 yeah
yeah yep yep man that's that creepy
thing that's that creepy think at some
point you were like oh look at that
little kid that's the Woody Allen moment
where you go oh isn't she adorable and
then at some point the switch flips to
being like hey I think I want to [ __ ]
that you know there's there's no way to
get around that sir you'd have to
understand that so anyways he says
nothing happened between us at that
point well I would hope so it wasn't
until we reconnected years later when we
were older that we started talking again
and really getting to know each other
alright well I guess that's fair but
people are gonna say some [ __ ] right
anyway I'm getting [ __ ] from some family
and friends because of our history just
from an outside source I'd like to know
what you think do you think it's strange
or weird I know there's people out there
15 to 20 years apart it's just with our
history it throws people off again what
do you think from an unbiased
perspective perspective thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself yeah the thing is is that
you were 17 and she was 10 when you
first met her that's what makes it weird
like my wife is ten years younger than
me but I didn't meet her until I was
like you know 35 and she was 25 hey Nia
come in here is a question somebody
somebody's 28 what do you say there
Wendy what he saw out of breath for come
here you know Jesus so this guy he's
dating this woman right he wants to
marry he's 28 she's 21
he said the thing is I met her when I
was a counselor I was 17 she was only 10
he goes obviously nothing happened then
but now that we're together people are
giving us [ __ ] and I was saying now
there was a ten-year difference between
us but I you know I was thirty-five year
25 so so they're looking at you like
you've been grooming her since she was
like yeah but he's like met her but then
didn't see me you didn't see her for a
while then they reconnected Natalie
chorus which happens don't worry about
it if you know everything's on the
up-and-up just just do your thing
yeah it's her family cool with it you
know is her family giving him the side
eye like he was grooming her or seems to
just be friends
well what do you mean he's friends
people that he knows it's just like this
is what I would do I would just whatever
those people are giving him [ __ ] about
it I wouldn't if you meet new people I
wouldn't tell them that that's how you
first met him
yeah probably not not everybody needs to
know your entire history in that way
just because people will misinterpret it
but yeah if you guys are fine your
families are fine like don't worry about
it yeah as long as nothing happened when
you were a counselor exactly as long as
you're sure nothing happened when you
were a counselor which I'm sure it
didn't he always wants to push her on
this wink oh god yeah it's bad all right
let's see you know I did it to you sir
you're gonna you're gonna have to you
know there's a certain level of [ __ ]
you're gonna have to deal with where are
you going I'm going out to have a little
a little breakfast with a friend I
didn't like the vagueness of that you
have a little breakfast with a friend
I'm going to get smoothies with chelsea
peretti
oh you didn't have to say that smoothy's
chelsea peretti
yeah sacramento zone chelsea peretti
yeah she's from sacramento no hella
sacramento she's white trash from she is
she's white trash from northern
california she is she's also a
Republican anyway all right where the
[ __ ] am i yeah do just you know give us
a [ __ ] this is the deal once you get
married you have [ __ ] kids and [ __ ]
you're never gonna see anybody anyway so
who gives a [ __ ] what gives a [ __ ] what
people think go out and do what makes
you happy okay as long as you're not
hurting anybody and you're not breaking
a lot please go out and do it before
just being happy becomes illegal because
you know just the level that the
population is going in you know I'm
thinking by the end of my life I don't
know what it's gonna be like over here I
hope we don't end up like China with
China it's so [ __ ] overpopulated they
got it like people nobody drive cars for
like five [ __ ] days and just the [ __ ]
that they're dealing with his brutal
over there what are you doing yeah take
the priests take the priests I still
have the Prius everybody I'm gonna be
selling the car I just can't find the
title so I sent I sent in all the forms
to the DMV by enjoy your smoothies you
big Hollywood phony all right so I send
it in to the local one and I [ __ ] up
not only did I send it to the wrong DMV
I wrote for some reason 2017 on the
check so they thought I was trying to be
pull a fast one so then I end up having
to send it up to [ __ ] Sacramento so
I'm waiting for that thing so I can
finally get rid of that of the [ __ ]
car all right here we go girlfriend
texts hey Bill I'm in in a bit of a
tough situation I think you are you
wrote in twice and would love to hear
you take it on it I'm 24 years old and
was recently seeing a 30
three year old girl whoa I love it bah
da do-do-do-do-do comment rub my [ __ ]
balls you were [ __ ] 9 years older for
about six months within the time span I
cheated on her twice I told her about it
at all though she was upset we agreed to
get back together and start over a new
everything was relatively fine until
last week I went to her house before she
got off of work to do some work on her
computer when I noticed her text
messages opened Oh Mac computers are
usually linked to a person's phone so I
was able to see all of her texts I'm
sure you know by now where this is going
oh geez since she has gone through my
texts before I figured I would take the
same evasive Liberty well you've [ __ ]
around on it twice I would think that
she would be doing that I found a
particularly strange thread from someone
named Lauren whom I found out was
actually her ex-boyfriend and she had it
in her phone and a woman's name Oh God
they were sexting back and forth talking
dirty and exchanging pictures I also
found out she was sending him videos of
us having sex what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] whoa dude that's it I don't think
that's legal is that legal
wait did you consent no wait how does
that work if you could essentially let
somebody if you didn't know you were
being filmed I don't think that that's
legal this is what I do know I'm not a
lawyer and I have no idea what the law
is all right let's continue I confronted
her on it and at first she minimized the
entire situation saying it wasn't really
that big of a deal since then we've been
going back and forth arguing you know
what you guys are both like not ready to
be in relationships remotely and thank
God you both found this out before you
got married and had kids she since
apologised but I'm not really sure what
to do I did cheat
her so does that even the playing field
or is the whole thing just rooted in
dysfunction in chaos there you go walk
towards the light I can't tell if I'm
just lonely and want her in my life
again or if I should just walk away
please help me Here I am emotionally
involved in this situation so it's hard
to make a clear objective call to just
walk away walk away and you need to do
some work on yourself
because I think you're a [ __ ] up dude
and I'm saying this with empathy you're
[ __ ] up dude who's actually
relationship guy and probably would have
just gotten married and [ __ ] had your
own little [ __ ] fruit stand or
whatever but something [ __ ] up happen
to you as a kid you got weird boundaries
so you get into relationships with
dysfunctional [ __ ] people and then
you could consider continue to [ __ ]
around on the side and all that the it's
it's actually a very common thing so I
would say what you need is you need to
be single and you need to do some work
on yourself I'm a would go to therapy
figure out what you deal is really
figure out what the [ __ ] it is that you
want in life and what it is that you're
looking for and then just take a baby
step everyday walking towards that's
what I would do but I would get out of
this relationship and I would give her
the same advice - there you go yeah get
out of it and and just know that you're
gonna be [ __ ] lonely but it all it
takes it's like do you know two to three
months you'll be fine you know I mean
just make yourself go to the gym what
you got to do is you're breaking a
routine and you [ __ ] use to this
person being in your life but like the
further you go without seeing that
person the more objective you can be and
you can look back and then one day
you're just gonna be at what the [ __ ]
was I thinking and it can actually be
funny to you or you can really just see
like like like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with me that I would do that to a person
and what is wrong with me that someone
would do that to me and I would consider
staying you need some self-esteem there
buddy alright girl with pet rat no Jesus
Christ
dear Billy Christmas toes I know what it
means I've been listening to the podcast
for a long time I recently came into a
situation that resulted in me having to
make a decision instead of writing in to
you and asking what to do in this
situation I decided to do what I thought
you would want me to do and write in
with the results do don't base your life
on what the [ __ ] you think I would want
to do but this is already interesting
last month a girl I had been dating got
a pet rat no boy got a pet [ __ ] rat
okay is it Angelina Jolie then she have
a rat on him she has Billy Bob's blood
around her neck we had been dating for
about four months and it was going well
I would say that if we were together
about six months I would have moved in
with her we really clicked well she got
a pet rat and I wasn't down with that
not because I had a problem with a rat
in a cage but her taking the rat out of
the cage and holding it while we watched
a movie bill I can barely even stand a
cat on a lap because I don't trust him
so I voiced my concern and she laughed
them off and ended up being a bigger
argument and eventually came back around
to the rat I told her it was me or the
rat she said she'd rather me oh you'd be
mr. word her she'd rather have me I
guess except it was a long pause and
some serious thought I really like this
girl and honestly if my devotion ever
came down to choosing between her and
anything short of family or friends
would she or any girl ever accept that
dude you're so emotional you skipping
words here probably not
they'd say bail on the guy who's not
sure if he'd choose you or something
that potentially spreads diseases
anyways that's what happened merry
Christmas to the birds
yeah but what you're doing is she loves
that rat and you're making her get rid
of something that she loves so there's
gonna be I guess a pause I don't know I
think that
it was really bugging you I think it was
really [ __ ] bothering you and you let
it simmer and then you just [ __ ] hit
it with you know you were ready to talk
about this for days weeks I don't know
how long and then you just [ __ ]
caught her off guard and she's been
bonding with this thing and you made her
make a Sophie's Choice between you or
the rat which I gotta tell you I don't
know about that move I don't know about
that move you could've easily just said
listen I respect the fact that you like
a rat okay well you know what the first
thing I would do is I would look up life
expectancy of a rat all right and I
don't mean someone that snitches because
I think everybody even I know at this
age as white as I am that snitches get
stitches no okay all right life
expectancy what do you guys think huh
what's the overrun here how long can a
[ __ ] rat live I'm gonna say they live
six to eight years you know if those are
the prices right now was the last person
to [ __ ] I would say six but I'm gonna
say eight eight years life expectancy of
a rat two years dude it only lives for
[ __ ] two years all right this is what
you say to her if she hasn't got rid of
the rat come back and say listen I know
you love that [ __ ] rodent here's the
deal the things only live two years all
right I plan on being with you in two
years can you do me a favor make this be
the only rat you ever have all right
okay she greases that thing and then
just put parameters when I come over and
we're watching Sleepless in Seattle I
don't want to have a threesome if you
know what I mean just keep it in the
[ __ ] cage when I'm not here you want
to roll around the floor get yellow
fever whatever the [ __ ] you wanted
whatever [ __ ] rats do if you want to
do that that's fine
I just you know I don't want to [ __ ]
deal with the thing you could have done
that but you know you kind of made her
like what's she gonna do with the rat
know like how to get rid of a rat is
there like a [ __ ] adoption agency
doesn't make me feel bad about my dog
again which is of course been brutal I'm
not gonna talk about it alright umm yeah
you just let the [ __ ] thing go do you
know those lions do you know once those
people have those [ __ ] lions and
tigers and cheetahs for long enough time
they can't release them back into the
wild because they don't even know how to
[ __ ] hunt anymore you don't I mean
that really blew my mind they don't have
a hunt anymore but they can murder a
[ __ ] housekeeper I mean he's just how
the [ __ ] do you have that in the house
there's no [ __ ] way
this wasn't Kuwait by the way I don't
know why I said Saudi Arabia Kuwait
exotic pet deaths let's see what we got
here
lions tigers become problems pets engulf
big cat killings maulings big cats
escape all right here we go this is 2014
this is a website you want to go to big
cat big cat rescue alright big cat
killings Molly's and escapes 2010's
before lion attacks on humans here's a
video I don't do I want to watch this
and is it weird that I root for the
[ __ ] animals oh Jesus Christ
alright to look at those things we were
I was talking to virzi and we were
talking about these big cats like those
big cats they're literally the
Lamborghinis and Ferraris of [ __ ] of
cats you know if some animals oh my god
it's [ __ ] it's got his [ __ ] arm
it's got his [ __ ] arm and he's trying
to slap at it oh my god Jesus [ __ ]
you
[ __ ] idiot this guy's trying to
remain calm
this is dude there's one guy he's
dealing with this lion attacking him and
then the [ __ ] there's another guy
slapping at the [ __ ] lion and it's
got his [ __ ] leg it's just sort of
holding him
he's almost away he's almost away oh my
God he's [ __ ] got him again dude you
should have got the [ __ ] out of there
get the [ __ ] out of there and this guy
he's still staying in the [ __ ] cage
well here you go you [ __ ] dope oh
this is like the top 10 all right you
got to go to this big cat rescue org and
this is another guy he's getting [ __ ]
bit by this goddamn thing it's weird man
when they decide that they're going
after somebody like the other guy can
just totally be like it too you know the
other guys like the friend in the bar
going come on man you don't need this
you don't need this this thing is just
going after this one [ __ ] dude lion
attack number eight alright he's petting
the back of the thing he's patting it
you know it's a [ __ ] lion and then
BOOM oh it's got his arm I've seen this
one it's got his [ __ ] arm now his
friends his friends are pulling it's a
tug of war with this guy right now and
the other guy is funny he tries to hit
the line but he's too afraid to go near
it so he keeps hitting his friend who
has it his [ __ ] mouth Wow
lion attacks hunter I've seen this one I
don't like that one cuz they killed a
[ __ ] light Jesus Christ you know what
I gotta be honest with you what you
don't see in any of these [ __ ] videos
is women that own [ __ ] these things
you know guys is just such [ __ ] dopes
anyways alright that's the podcast for
this week guys if you guys missed last
Thursday's podcasts you got a tune into
a rich side no man this guy gives you
basically a stand-up comedy history
class he's one of my favorite guests
I've ever had on the podcast I could
have talked to him for like two hours
you have to get his book
you know it's about his life as a
stand-up comedian was it walking through
the ashes of stand up my life as a
stand-up comedian you got to get the
book because you know he started to tell
me those Johnny because the first time
he did The Tonight Show he had cocaine
bag a little baggie of cocaine in his
[ __ ] pocket
he said the next time he did it he did a
joke about heart attacks and johnny was
really nervous about having a heart
attack because he smoked and hated him
and they made sure they stayed in the
[ __ ] dressing room there like he'd
never do in the show again and blah blah
blah and all this type of shit's [ __ ]
the book is amazing but you got to
listen listen to the podcast we I have
the links and everything who's last
Thursday Polly if you're really a fan of
stand-up
it was just effortless it was one of the
fastest hours I've ever done in the
podcast totally fascinating please check
it out it was from what's today's date I
don't [ __ ] know it was last Thursday
goddamn it bill let's see Thursday the
we'll see 11 12 13 14 to 15th not Jesus
bill come on Jenny can you get you [ __ ]
together here alright 2016 yeah Thursday
the 15th check that one alright that's
podcasts go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check
in on ya on Thursday